One Piece is THE BEST LIVE ACTION ADAPTATION EVER.
But there are a TON OF CHANGES that were made from
the original story, like how instead of meeting
Zoro tied up at the marine base he is literally
introduced by chopping this dude in half,
stuffing him into a bag, and taking him straight
into a bar. Seriously, what is going on!?
And speaking of bars, they also added NEON
LIGHTS to many of the bars. Like, what???
I guess the whole world has upgraded
because electricity is just a common
thing pretty much everywhere. It even shows
up on battleships and in Kaya’s mansion.
But now let’s go back to the very beginning for
THE BIGGEST CHANGE in the entire live action.
That’s because Vice-Admiral Garp shows up at
Roger’s execution and gives this super serious
speech which is not like his character from
the original show AT ALL. But this was just
the start because Garp’s ENTIRE storyline of
chasing down Luffy was completely made up for
the live action. Although he did originally train
Koby and Helmeppo. And while I enjoyed the added
development for Koby, the extra tension of
the marine threat, and some MIND-BLOWINGLY
HILARIOUS Helmeppo scenes that we’ll talk
about in just a moment, the overall vibe
of Garp barely resembled the loose-cannon,
rule-breaking Vice-admiral from the anime.
And speaking of the LEGENDARY Helmeppo,
he was pretty much just a goofy character
from the anime but he had the MOST SHOCKING
scene in the entire live action when he was
caught BUTT NAKED playing with Zoro’s sword.
What’s even more impressive though is the
ABSOLUTE POWERHOUSE of a battleship that Garp
now rides around on. Honestly, this is much more
intimidating than his original ship in the anime.
However, one of the MOST DISAPPOINTING
CHANGES for me was that the Live Action
COMPLETELY SKIPPED the very end of
Luffy’s backstory. In the anime,
this scene shows Luffy at age 17
ready to set out on his adventure.
And as he leaves he lands a MASSIVE PUNCH that
completely knocks out this giant sea monster,
showing us all just how much Luffy has grown.
But nope, just completely cut from this version.
But maybe they skipped it for this INSANE
REASON because there is no doubt in my mind
that the Live Action versions of the
characters are WAY WEAKER than in the
original story. I mean they were literally
trapped by Buggy inside a simple wooden box
but Zoro and Luffy were SO WEAK that
they couldn’t even break out. Though
later on Luffy can apparently punch through
stone, so a bit of a head scratcher there.
One other awesome change is that Nami’s
first staff can now collapse into a size
that can be easily carried on her
waist. Pretty cool if you ask me.
And speaking of Nami, we see her ACTUALLY
DOING burglar stuff in the Live Action
like breaking into a safe! Which sadly we
never actually saw much during the anime.
Plus I was COMPLETELY SHOCKED when Nami
saw the DEVASTATING DAMAGE Buggy did to
Orange Town. Damn, this had WAY
MORE impact than in the manga.
But that’s not the only change in
Buggy’s part of the story because
in the Live Action clown is 10 TIMES
MORE EVIL than in the anime. Originally
he never kidnapped all the villagers
or threatened to torture a little kid.
And the Live Action even gave us a
super rare Big Brain Luffy moment,
when he came up with the plan to trap Buggy’s
body parts in the crates. If you compare this
exact moment to the manga it was Nami who
decided to tie up Buggy’s limbs with some rope.
However, the reward for saving this village was
NOTHING COMPARED to what it was in the anime.
That’s because the Mayor of Orange Town offered
Live Action Luffy this tiny basket of food,
but in the original, the crew came away
with giant sacks stuffed full of goodies.
This brings us to one of the MOST
CONTROVERSIAL changes in the Live Action,
which was all the times Nami hinted that
she was never going to betray the crew.
And while they did this weird “she’s staying,
oh wait she’s not staying” thing during Baratie,
overall I feel that they kinda
spoiled the one mind-blowing
twist from the original East Blue story
when Nami abandoned the crew at Baratie.
Though it was AMAZING to see these
mini earbud transponder snails,
which never showed up in the original story.
And now we come to the SINGLE-MOST CHANGED ARC
of the entire story. And that is Syrup Village,
where we meet Usopp for the first time. And
man this place is SO DIFFERENT. Because the
Live Action turned this tiny little village in
the hills into a super busy shipbuilding island.
And at first I HATED THIS but I
finally came around to like it
when the live action added Luffy
describing his perfect ship which
just goes to show how important
the ship is as part of the crew.
Plus they actually gave Usopp a
brand new job working on ships,
which helps explain his ability to fix up
the Merry during their future adventures.
But that’s just the start of the WILD CHANGES
in Syrup Village because Nami bonding with Kaya
was NEVER part of the original story. Though
I will admit the added character development
for Kaya was awesome, and she even gave my man
Usopp THE VERY FIRST KISS in the entire story.
Just don’t tell Sanji about that.
But then they dropped the ball on Kaya’s entire
story arc by cutting out THE ONE SCENE where she
actually stands up to Kuro. Seriously this was her
one moment to show some courage, but nope. Gone.
And speaking of Kuro, they cut out almost
his entire crew. Which you know is kinda
important for a pirate captain. And if that
wasn’t bad enough they left him with probably
the most cringe characters in the entire show,
Sham and Buchi. Plus they cut out this dude,
who was one of my favorite parts
of this entire arc in the anime.
We also have to mention the changes to this
sheep-head dude’s story. Unlike in the anime,
Merry is not a butler but instead he is Kaya’s
financial advisor. Which is honestly a bit sad
because he was one of Kaya’s only friends in
her entire house. Then of course he ends up
actually dying unlike in the anime where he
survived and gave the crew the ship himself.
But now we have some of the
WORST CHANGES in the live action,
which unfortunately all involve Usopp.
First, they took away his long nose.
Then they made Usopp do LITERALLY
NOTHING during the final fight to
save Kaya. He is supposed to be a coward
who overcomes his fear, not JUST A COWARD.
But the WORST PART is that he
cannot even fire a cannon. This
is unacceptable! He is supposed
to be an expert sharpshooter who
can hit a rock super far away. That is
his one thing! And they took it away!
But enough of Usopp, let’s talk
about a really dumb change for
Zoro’s backstory. That’s because in the
original story, we see Zoro talking to
the master of the dojo before Kuina ever
even dies. However, in the Live Action,
they literally never interact until Kuina’s death
which makes for this awkward exchange where Zoro
has to ask for Kuina’s sword instead of
Koushirou giving it to him on his own.
They also made Kuina’s hair super blue for
some weird reason, instead of its normal
black.And Zoro’s famous sword is also slightly
changed, as the blade is missing the normal black
part of the blade on the non-cutting side.
Instead it is just this uniform shiny metal.
But the change I’ve been complaining about since
the very first promotional image is the
way the Merry’s figurehead looks. Uhh,
is supposed to be the perfect friendly
little sheep, not the stuff of nightmares.
But another thing that made NO SENSE was
how Luffy didn’t even know that he could
blow himself up to block this cannonball. I
mean he’s had his devil fruit for over ten
years, and in the anime he was doing way
crazier stuff than this with no problem.
Now let’s move onto probably THE MOST
AMAZING change in the entire live action,
which is that they turned Sanji’s pervertedness
meter all the way down to zero. Seriously,
it’s like he’s a new man who just happens
to enjoy filtering with the ladies like
Nami and Nojiko instead of being super over
the top weird with girls like in the anime.
And honestly, almost all of the changes at
Bartie were FANTASTIC. It looks INCREDIBLE.
And the best part was that this place gave us
drunk Usopp. What else could we possibly ask for?
They also changed the reason Luffy was
forced to work for Zeff. Originally,
Luffy launched a cannonball which
crashed into the floating restaurant,
so he was forced to work to pay off the damage.
But in the Live Action he just didn’t have any
money to pay the bill. Which makes sense,
but is less cool in my humble opinion.
Plus the decision to COMPLETELY ELIMINATE Don
Krieg from ever showing up to Baratie was a
simply amazing choice. Because while I don’t
love the fact that Garp felt he needed to call
Mihawk for help, the world’s strongest
swordsman’s new introduction showed us
just how badass he truly is without wasting
a ton of time by bringing Kreig to Baratie.
And can I just say I LOVE that they
introduced the fishmen in this arc. From
this fishman serving as the restaurant's front
of house to Arlong showing up like a mob boss
for the entire East Blue it all worked
well to expand the scope of the world.
However, Arlong’s fight with Luffy in episode
six shows off one of the WORST MISTAKES in
the entire show. That’s because
when Arlong sends Luffy flying,
we can clearly see that he is actually
hurting from these blows. However,
in reality Luffy’s rubber body should make
him immune to damage from regular punches,
kicks, and even bullets, like we saw early
in episode one when Alivda smashed him with
her club and shot him. The only thing that
should really cause him any damage at this
point are sharp objects like blades or teeth
and of course the obvious threat of drowning.
And the original luffy would NEVER
get crushed by Arlong in this scene,
because he is way stronger than the
fishman, but I guess we can say it’s
because this version of Luffy is
weaker than the anime version.
Also can we just point out how
much Usopp’s slingshot looks
like a toy. I honestly never got that
feeling when seeing it in the anime.
Now if you’ve watched through the Water 7 arc in
the anime then you should find this next new scene
HILARIOUS! That’s because when Sanji is talking
to Luffy and Usopp on the Merry, he says that a
captain’s decisions are what separates him from
the rest of the crew. And then Luffy literally
looks right at Usopp! Which is such a fun easter
egg for viewers who know what happens later on.
And earlier I said Syrup village looked way
different, but this next set is also WAY DIFFERENT
from its original. In the anime, Coco Village is
shown as a tropical paradise which hides the dark
secrets, but in the live action they transformed
it into a SUPER rural village full of huts. Which
makes sense since these people are being bed dry,
but I still miss the appearance of the anime.
Arlong park also had a SERIOUS MAKEOVER.
They basically made it a club with some
random carnival games thrown in there which
is a lot different from the original location.
The Live Action also made a really confusing
choice during this arc. That’s because originally
the people in Coco Village knew about Nami’s
sacrifice to work for Arlong from the very
beginning. Which made them never hate her. But
in the live action, they don’t know anything
and there’s this super rough dynamic of Nami
literally forcing the villagers to cough up
more cash. And these people who are supposed
to love her think she is a traitor. Plus then
she had to spell it out for Nojiko so her
own sister wouldn’t hit her with a shovel.
They also cut these two bounty hunter brothers and
this Octopus fishman. Which is understandable why
they cut the octopus because honestly it would
take a lot of cgi to make his character work.
But he does play a pretty important role in the
future, so I wonder if they’ll bring him back.
But now let’s discuss some awesome and also
bizarre changes about the world’s greatest
swordsman. In the live action Mihawk actually
never came to Baratie looking for Luffy. He
only came to the floating restaurant chasing
after Don Kreig, but in this version he weirdly
follows actual orders from the marines
which is way out of character for him.
The Live Action Mihawk also makes a direct
comment about Luffy’s hat, which is such
cool foreshadowing of his connection to Shank.
And he even goes on to compare Luffy to Roger,
which is the same thing that Zeff does
when talking to Garp. So there a lot
more obvious connections to Luffy and
Roger than WE EVER HAD in the anime.
But the ABSOLUTE WORST CHANGE they made
to this awesome character is his boots!
Just look at these things. And I
have nothing against cowboy boots,
but honestly it looks like he is ready
to ride a bull not fight legendary duels.
And speaking of character designs, they made SO
MANY AMAZING improvements on characters’ outfits.
In particular the straw hats, who wear many of the
outfits we see on the volume covers on the manga,
instead of sticking with the same
clothes for most of the East Blue.
Although some changes were a bit too far out
there for me, like Sanji literally wearing
vans while stranded during his flashback.
There were also Ben Beckman AND Bellemere,
who both looked much older than
they did in the original story.
But THE WORST character design change just has to
be Arlong, and that’s because the dude is JUST.
TOO. SMALL. In the anime the fishman towers over
Luffy and the crew, which really adds a sense of
intimidation and fear. I mean just look at
this guy. He is basically twice as tall as
Genzo. But in the live action, he is just slightly
taller, which just doesn’t have the same effect.
Another very odd change was that they made
Nami bury her treasure right next to her
mother’s grave. I mean, Nojiko even pointed
out how messed up that is. In the anime
Bellemere’s grave was by the ocean and Nami
kept her money buried in the tangerine grove.
But there is one other MAJOR change to
this arc that I haven’t mentioned yet,
and that is everything involving Buggy
the Clown, so if you want to hear my
full thoughts on his added involvement in the
story you can watch my full review right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll
see you in the next one.